here now with reaction the former
Director of National Intelligence John
Ratcliffe director thanks for joining us
I had the pleasure of serving with you
in the United States uh Congress but uh
thrilled to to be chatting with you
about this because uh as the Director of
National Intelligence you yeah you saw
you saw the top level intelligence of
this country what's your read on what's
going on in the Middle East now because
boy we take a 100 attacks and do the
bare minimum to say the
least
yeah Jason by the Biden administration's
own admission um they have failed to
accomplish the Strategic deter uh
deterrence that they promis you you
remember when these attacks that you
just mentioned started in the aftermath
of the uh October 7th attack uh in ga uh
in Gaza um the the Biden Administration
stood at the podium John Kirby secretary
defense Austin they said we will respond
in a manner and method of our choosing
but we promise you that we will deter
these types of attacks from happening in
the future well at that time they were
at 20 now as you said Jason were well
over a 100 attacks and Jason the attacks
you mentioned yesterday were from uh K
Hezbollah but the week before they were
from the houi rebels and and of course
uh Hamas didn't just kill 1400 Jews they
killed 32 Americans at least on October
7th and took about it a dozen American
hostages so you know the Biden
administration's running out of Terror
cells to get pushed around by in the
Middle East and of course all of those
groups that I just mentioned Jason
they're all controlled by funded by Iran
and what's so frustrating um when you
talk about you know the intelligence
that I've seen is you know at the end of
our Administration we handed the Biden
Administration peace in the Middle East
we handed them the Abraham Accords and
we handed them an Iran that was bankrupt
uh that was incapable of funding these
type of Terror activities um you know
they were focused on regime survival
alone and they didn't have money for the
houthis Hamas and Hezbollah names that
have now become uh household names for
all the wrong reasons in the Biden
administration because they have failed
to accomplish strategic deterrence
against our
adversaries well the polling has
certainly gone sour for for Joe Biden I
don't see anybody really in the United
States as thrilled with how he's
handling this and it how do what's your
read of that why is that because it
doesn't seem that anybody's happy with
how the response is
going well I think like a lot of his
foreign policy decisions um they've been
schizophrenic I mean in in this case
he's expressed support for Israel
verbally but then he's paraded one
official after another to meet with
Netanyahu and other other Israeli
Israeli officials to pressure them to
end the campaign um against Hamas in a
matter of weeks something that our own
intelligence tells us is impossible uh
this has got to continue to destroy
Hamas it's a campaign that's going to
have to last last for months and yet
he's asking the Israelis to do the
impossible so as a result he's he's
engaged in a policy that's making no one
happy some people think he's supporting
Israel too much some people think he's
supporting Hamas too much uh and only a
few people think he's getting it just
right and you know I think this is
unfortunately uh something that we've
seen throughout the administration it's
not just here in the Middle East Jason I
would challenge you to find a place on
the globe where US National Security
interests have improved in the Biden
Administration and where the National
Security interests of our enemies and
adversaries have waned it's certainly
not the Middle East it's not Asia where
China has push us around it's not Europe
where Putin has now invaded Ukraine
twice while Biden's been in the white
house it's not in Central and South
America where we're currently seeing
what is commonly being referred to as
the Biden invasion of our Southern
border so everywhere uh America sees
they see failure from the Biden
Administration from a foreign policy
standpoint and and I get that you know
Biden nomics and the domestic policy has
been a disaster but I would submit to
you um as the former Director of
National Intelligence that their foreign
policy has been an even greater
failure well let's talk about that
because now we have secretary Marcus
secretary blinkin headed down to Mexico
to to to talk with the the Mexican
Government I don't know what their
message is I I the only policy I see out
of Joe Biden and KLA Harris is one of
open borders and and an invitation to
come to this country because nothing's
going to happen to you if become
illegally we'll give you a free plane
ride give you a they give you a phone
and then we'll give you housing and
everything else that's what I see them
doing I don't know what in the world
they're going to ask from the Mexican
Government well and you know um Lopez
opor the president of Mexico you know he
sees what's happening around the world
and and the idea that he's going to do
what the Biden Administration asks um
without uh the the threat of imposing
some cost on Mexico that they can't
sustain it's just not going to happen
look at the end of our Administration uh
we had a secure border and we had Mexico
enforcing their border because we had
the remain in Mexico policy Jason in our
transition we told the Biden
Administration if you reverse this
policy you're going to create a crisis
at the border you're going to have these
Caravans coming up that's exactly
exactly what's happened so they created
this crisis at the border and it's not
going to go away unless they're willing
to impose costs on Mexico uh like we did
in the Trump Administration but they
haven't been willing to impose sanctions
or costs on any um countries to get them
to do the things that the United States
need to do for our own National Security
interests that's right whether it be the
Middle East in China uh down in Mexico
we speak a language that nobody is
understanding because we don't stand up
for ourselves we don't stand up for the
United States of America we act like a
second class citizen that's just going
to let everybody else roll right over us
and and I'm I'm tired of it I think the
American people are tired of it and uh
listen I appreciate your perspective and
the great role you played the former
Director of National Intelligence John
Ratcliffe joining us tonight out of
Texas thank you for so much for joining
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else